wir müssen an dieser stelle über einen
neuen badeunfall berichten einen
tödlichen ein vierjähriges mädchen ist
in bayern gestorben
im kratzmühle das ist bei eichstätt
besonders schlimm eine schülerin findet
das mädchen und dazu sprechen möchten
wir jetzt auch direkt mit meinem
kollegen jörg völkerling er ist vor ort
jörg was wissen wir denn über diesen
tragischen badeunfall wieder der fall an
sich ist heute durch eine
pressemitteilung des polizeipräsidiums
oberbayern nord bekannt geworden
abgespielt hat sich das hier am kreuz am
kratz musée im oberbayerischen landkreis
eichstätt bei kinding bereits gestern
nachmittag die zeiten sind relativ gut
dokumentiert wir haben dieses foto
gesehen das amen im leben gekommenen
mädchens das um 14 uhr 32 entstanden ist
und um 15 uhr 3 hat einen augenzeugen
und ersthelferin mit der wir sprechen
konnten auch schon den notruf
verständigt
wir wissen auch aus der pressemitteilung
der polizei dass eine schülerin ein
teenie offenbar von der terrasse des
heeres des restaurants dass ich hier
hinter mir befindet
dieses mädchen gesehen hat in dieser
pressemitteilung heißt es dass die
schülerin habe das kind mit den armen
fuchteln sehen
es gibt dem widersprechen die
zeugenaussagen die sagen das sei nicht
der fall gewesen das kind müsse ganz
still und leise untergegangen sein und
dazu habe ich mit der altenpflegerin
melanie z gesprochen sie ist 22 sie war
gestern nachmittag am freitagnachmittag
der war viel schöner als heute 18 grad
wärmer mit ihren drei kindern hier am
strand zum baden und sie ihre kinder
begegneten diesen vierjährigen mädchen
das war sehr offenherzig kam auf sie
zugelaufen und fragte ob es nicht mit
den anderen kindern spielen können und
muscheln sammeln dürfen und ob man nicht
gemeinsam tauchen wolle und nach den
schilderungen dieser augenzeugen befand
sich die mutter des mädchens der zeit
als das kind im wasser war auf der
terrasse des restaurants und sie soll
auch als die schülerin das kind am
ertrinken quasi beobachtet habe soll sie
nicht sofort mit eingeschritten sein
soll nicht zur hilfe gekommen sein dass
es jetzt nicht verifiziert
die polizei selber hüllt sich in
schweigen mein kollege jakob mail hat
die polizei damit konfrontiert sie sagen
sie machen keine angaben zur mutter da
steht natürlich auch eine
aufsichtspflichtverletzung irgendwo im
raum
ich weiß jedenfalls von der augenzeugen
melanie c
die macht sich die allergrößten vorwürfe
auch wenn das eigentlich überhaupt nicht
gerechtfertigt ist sie sagt sie hätte
das noch bemerken müssen wenn da ein
kind vor ihren augen untergeht
aber sie habe einfach gedacht dieses
mädchen das da vor ihr mit ohne
schwimmflügel aufgetaucht war sie hatte
gedacht sie sei einfach zu ihrer mutter
gegangen auch die terrasse und dann
konnte sie nur noch nach den schreien
der schülerin von der terrasse ins
wasser rennen mit einem anderen helfer
zusammen dieses kind dann aus dem wasser
holen
da war es aber wohl schon blau
angelaufen und der später hinzukommende
notarzt hat festgestellt dass das kind
wohl schon seit zehn minuten in diesem
teilweise bis zu neun meter tiefen
baggersee gewesen sein muss da war das
wirklich ganz tragisch was so das geht
ans herz bekommt auch ganz schwitzige
hände bei diesem thema trotzdem danke
für diesen moment an dich